foreign
[Music]
the top stories live from the Sky News
City Studio
the UK's Financial Watchdog moves to
make the UK stock market more attractive
to companies I'll be hearing from its
chief executive
Lloyd's Banker group profits up by 46 in
the first quarter as it benefits from
rising interest rates
all eyes on the U.S federal reserve were
the 10th consecutive rise in its key
policy rate expected today
plus the tourism Revival continues as
Trivago posts a 90 rise in sales for the
first three months of the year
[Music]
good morning this is Ian King live in
our business and economic news from the
Heart of the City well the financial
conduct Authority has proposed
simplifying the UK's listing rules to
encourage more companies to float on the
stock market here since 2008 the number
of listings in the UK has fallen by 40
with many companies looking overseas
instead the uk-based chip designer arm
Holdings has opted to list in New York
rather than London while the building
materials company crh and the gaming
group flutter entertainment are both
moving their main listing from London to
New York well asked nickelrighty the
cfca chief executive about the impetus
for the changes
we made changes two years ago to
make it simpler to list particularly for
technology companies and we opened a
discussion at that point around whether
we should make any further changes and
so what we've proposed this morning are
some further simplifications to move
from having two segments to one segment
make it easier for companies that have
recently started to access the public
markets and also move to a more
disclosure-based regime so that they can
grow and undertake significant
transactions faster that with that
brings with it though also more risk and
that's the debate we're very keen for
everybody to participate in as we
discuss these proposals are these
proposals a recognition that what you
did two years ago wasn't sufficiently
radical
what we did two years ago was moved to a
system which enabled dual class shares
for example to be used we constantly
look at feedback from the market we look
at what's happening around the world and
we keep adjusting and that's the
discussion we've been having and we're
now ready to crystallize that debate um
with new rules well we're only one part
of a much broader ecosystem so while
regulation plays A Part there are many
other bigger issues that also need to be
looked at for example the role of
Pension funds in the UK and how they
allocate risk Capital our culture our
business environment tax issues also the
access that UK has to overseas markets
all of those need to feature in this
discussion when you talk about tax
issues is that perhaps a recognition
that things like stamp Duty on share
dealing may have to change that's been
in the UK for centuries and we charge
0.5 percent on every transaction
different markets tax their transactions
in different ways we just need to
understand what the different choices
are there when pensions dividend tax was
changed in the late 1990s that along
with accounting changes global economic
shifts new products also change the
incentives for Pension funds all of
these things I think are ripe for
discussion as we look to make sure we've
got markets that are fit for the future
they enable companies of all sizes to
access them you mentioned the role of
Pension funds there isn't the main
reason that they've fallen out of love
with UK equities because they now have a
very specific mandate you mentioned
accounting changes there to match their
assets with their liabilities and the
easiest way for them to do that is via
bonds
that's been described as the issue for
defined benefit Pension funds and that's
part of the discussion at the same time
we have a very fast growing defined
contribution pension fund system with
over a trillion expected from UK Savers
in that system over the next few years
what's important is that those savings
can be allocated to growth and to an
appropriate level of risk for UK saver
so that Savers get the pension returns
thereafter are you saying then that the
people who manage DC pension schemes are
too risk-averse I'm saying we have to
make sure that the right incentives in
the system so that the economy gets the
financing it needs and Savers get the
returns and thereafter we have several
thousand Pension funds both DC and DB
and there is a question about whether
that is the right system to enable
investment in long-term infrastructure
and growing companies other similar
markets have many more smaller Pension
funds but much larger in scale able to
invest in the expertise and the analysis
they need to make long-term Investments
now one of the main proposals you're
making is to do away with standard and
premium listings and just have one one
class of listing what are the specific
benefits of that investor feedback that
we've been getting is that having two
segments can be a little bit confusing
and having a single route to accessing
the public markets with one set of clear
rules would be potentially a more
attractive model for both companies
looking to raise capital and investors
that's the discussion we're opening
today with that though comes as I've
said a transfer of risk to investors and
that's a very important part of the
conversation to make sure that investors
understand their responsibilities to
hold companies to account but also they
will be taking on more obligations to
Value companies and engage with
companies well you're also suggesting
that companies listing don't have to
produce three years worth of financial
accounts prior to doing so I mean some
people will say that's a recipe for
disaster these are the choices we're
making but sometimes these startup
companies particularly in the technology
domain can grow incredibly fast and we
can see that you can go from having a
very low market share in a particular
product to a very large scalable company
so we want to make sure that Founders as
they're scaling up have the opportunity
to access public markets we saw during
the pandemic the ability for investors
to make judgments around companies and
investing in the UK 34 billion pounds of
capital in 2020 even when the accounting
certainty wasn't there because of the
nature of what was going on around the
world so part of this is a choice for
investors to make as to whether they
wish to invest in companies of that
nature isn't this though more to do with
the mindset of investors in the UK stock
market I mean even if you leave aside
tech companies for a moment you look at
an established business like BP
it's rated far more lowly than its peers
in the United States even though it's
the quality of its earnings are just as
high
everybody's going to trade statistics
about relative valuations it's worth
bearing in mind that the majority of
investors in the UK stock market now are
overseas investors who buy stocks both
here and in markets around the world
what is important I think is that
investors also invest in their ability
to understand companies understand their
financials engage with the management of
those companies and the boards to get to
the appropriate valuation for their risk
appetite the question about risk I think
is an important one and the mindset
around growth is an important one more
criticism we hear is that firms in the
UK find it hard to raise scale-up
Capital we think this can help but this
is only one part of an ecosystem there's
also the question of private markets and
all of the different spectrum of
financing possibilities on the way to
the public market all of those need to
be functioning effectively do you think
have these proposals been implemented it
would have been enough to persuade a
company like arm Holdings to list in
London rather than New York or as well
as New York
I think it's very unlikely that a
specific regulatory change impacts a an
individual decision in the case of arm
in 2016 when the company was sold the
Takeover panel in the UK didn't apply
any restrictions to how the capital for
that company could be raised in the
future other countries like Australia
take a different approach to companies
of national importance we're a Global
Financial Center we take a much more
open approach but that's also a question
I think for for the government to
consider in terms of how it wishes to
think about Market access and some of
these issues around incentives to stay
in the Home Market
don't you think the attractiveness of
public markets against say being private
is being watered down by the fact that
for a lot of CEOs in particular it's not
much fun running a public company
anymore you your salaries in the
newspapers all of your time is taken up
with sort of corporate governance issues
and other various pieces of regulatory
reporting that you just don't get on
private markets
public markets are by definition public
so when you're selling your shares you
are drawing in capital from a wide range
of investors institutions in the UK
around the world retail investors as
well that comes with it disclosure and
accountability but it can also provide
access to Capital on a scale that's not
available elsewhere I mentioned earlier
during the pandemic 34 billion pounds of
secondary Capital was raised in the UK
Market at speed when companies needed
support most to make sure that they
could secure their Futures the future
jobs for their employees and the growth
that there was needed for the economy so
with that access to Capital comes a
comes a trade-off in terms of
transparency and accountability I'm
getting the sense from talking to you
that you really think there needs to be
a sort of reappraisal of risk appetites
in in the UK Market
I think we need to have an honest
conversation around the level of risk
that we're willing to bear and the
system as it moves to a more
disclosure-based system if that's where
Market consensus lands following this
discussion will entail more risk that
means that there is upside for investors
but it also means that sometimes things
will go wrong and that's part of a
healthy Dynamic Capital Market and we
need to in discussion with Market
participants work out where we want to
strike that balance
that was nicarati from the FCA speaking
to me a little earlier well later today
the U.S federal reserve is expected to
raise its key policy rate fed funds for
the 10th consecutive time since March
last year it's expected to raise fed
funds from the current rate of four and
three quarter to five percent to five to
five and a quarter percent which is the
highest level in nearly 16 years the
speed with which central banks around
the world have raised interest rates has
caused upheaval across numerous
financial markets and across various
asset classes we're joining me now
Stephen Cohen he's head of Europe Middle
Eastern Africa at BlackRock the world's
largest asset management firm Stephen
Vega morning to you before we talk about
those macro things love to get your
reaction to what the FCA is proposing do
you think they'll fly
I you know this has been a conversation
over the last two three years as we just
heard and I think that the uh the Lord
Hill listings review which really was
the kind of uh culmination and a lot of
work in terms of how do you ensure this
uh progression of competitiveness and I
think the UK Financial secretary is
absolutely critical to the UK economy
you've got to keep it competitive you've
got to keep the city competitive and
you've got to balance that with ensuring
that you have that strength of
governance and regulation which has
always been one of the factors behind
the success of the city over the last 30
years so clearly there's some details in
what has been announced this morning
we're going to look through in terms of
the consultation but the overall
direction of travel I think is exactly
the right one I mean the central driver
for this is that the institutional fund
managers the people who run our
retirement savings like you have turned
you back on UK equities how do you
respond to that I don't think we've
turned our back on your characters I
think it's a case of you've got to
ensure that uh you know the money you're
managing you're managing on behalf of
your clients ultimately we manage for
example 11 million uh pension pensioners
we may there's money for 11 million
pensions in the UK our job is to ensure
that they have the right retirement when
they come to retire so we can look
everywhere in the world and and to build
those portfolios to deliver those
returns I think the types of things
we're hearing today and we've been
talking about hopefully will encourage
more companies to grow in the UK I think
the mention around not just about
there's a great startup scene how do you
create that scale-up scene how do you
attract that Capital how do you then
make sure the companies feel that this
is the place they want to list and they
want to be long term and I think any
step towards that is going to make it
more attractive for any Global investor
to think about the UK in terms of that
aspect of their portfolios I mean
there's a clear implication in all of
this that UK investors are slightly
risk-averse but is there a danger that
he Waters down the regulations so much
so that we get all sorts of Duds
floating on the market that we otherwise
wouldn't have that's why you've got to
find the right balance and I think I
think they've been steady you know being
steady as to how they've approached that
I think there is a strong awareness that
governance is absolutely crucial and as
I say earlier on you know the the UK is
known for strong regulatory standards
it's actually one of the things that has
attracted Capital to the UK so you don't
want to water that down to the point
where that goes away but you do need to
balance that I think with more
competitiveness with change of actually
makes companies and management feel like
this is the place for them long term and
if you do that you're going to deliver
ultimately returns if you encourage more
domestic Capital that will encourage
more companies to stay so there is a
virtuous circle here I think they're
trying to create but why do you think
the UK does trade at this discount to
other markets I mean if you take a
company like BP its earnings are very
very similar to those of say Chevron in
the United States yet the latter is
valued at far far more highly than than
BP is I think they're very they're you
can look at lots of different companies
and lots of sectors and there are very
specific reasons why any given company
you might see that kind of valuation
difference uh um whether that's specific
to the company or whether that's
specific to the sector I think that
there is an overall need to try and
encourage more UK Capital to invest in
productive assets uh and you know the
the interview prior just talked about
for example uh defined contributions how
do you really activate this huge amount
of money that is in defined contribution
schemes today and will grow hugely over
the coming years how do you ensure that
that is going into productive assets
that work both for the beneficiaries but
also have that potential knock-on effect
that actually you can encourage
long-term growth in the UK and again
kind of invest in some of those future
future companies yeah there's a lot of
talk about consolidation of some of
these DC schemes would that be a Magic
Bullet in Your View I don't think
anything's a Magic Bullet but I do think
that if you think about where can you
take the pension system anything that
allows the pension system to have a
greater scale both in terms of you know
potentially reducing cost but also that
ability to run uh portfolios that are
going to deliver better returns I think
is a good thing now as I mentioned in
the introduction the FED meets later
today the the Market's expecting another
rate Riser is it nailed on in your view
in our view it pretty much is
um you know I think that uh you know
clearly a little bit of a wobble over
the last couple of days has reduced some
expectations but our our thinking is
that they will they will hike today but
then we're probably going to move into a
phase of palsy and I think this is going
to what will be what we're going to see
actually for most of the domestic the
the big central banks around the world
including the bank of England and
ultimately the ECB as well which is that
they've done a huge amount I mean this
is the biggest fastest interest rate
hiking cycle we've seen since the 1980s
so we can't forget that we're now at a
point where actually all of that happens
in with a lag so now I think we move
into this phase of as the economy slows
into the second half of this year which
we think it will into what is likely to
be a mild recession as that happens we
think the central banks go on pause
and actually there's an assessment of
actually what has been the impact of
this hiking cycle that we've seen
including the fact that as we know in
the US everything has happened in the
regional banking sector the last two
months is having an impact on credit
conditions and we're going to see that
start to play through and as that starts
to play through that'll do some of the
fed's work as well the challenge is that
inflation is still not down anywhere
near their target and so I think what
you do end up where we where we kind of
disagree with some of the market pricing
at the moment is the idea that the FED
will be in a position say in Q4 to
actually start to cut rates in a slowing
economy because we just think this core
of services inflation is sticky enough
that it's going to restrict the central
bank's ability to cut
so we probably go into a pause and then
a hold phase as they assess market
conditions and do you think that has
already started to be priced in by
Equity markets I mean if you look at you
know whether it's the stock 600 here in
Europe or the the s p in in the US I
mean they've all made a really good good
start to the year they've had a
fantastic start so compared to kind of
expectations uh you know generally as a
most asset classes have done very well
and and I think partly that's because
actually economic data particularly in
the US has been stronger than expected
we've had a lot of support from U.S
consumers they've been very very
resilient they're spending down the
coveted savings that they built up so
that's one factor and the second factor
is that actually earnings have generally
been kind of better than than some of
the expectations so we haven't really
seen we're seeing an earning slowdown
but we haven't necessarily seen the
Slowdown that that many people expected
now I think there's still risks in the
second half that that does start to come
through given what we just talked about
and so that not hasn't necessarily been
priced into to equities at this level so
you think investors are still being a
little too penguin right now well it's
interesting I think that these markets
are kind of drifting up without a huge
amount of of activity uh and so I think
investors are being actually
um very focused on
um this the reality that you know cash
offers a lot of uh high yield now uh and
so what is the new benefit that's the
new Benchmark when you think about uh
you know overall building of portfolios
absolutely I could talk to you all
morning but before I let you go um
Activision said last week after its
takeover by Microsoft has blocked here
in the UK that Britain was closed for
business how would you respond to that
I don't think Britain is close to
business
um but we wouldn't speak about any
specific kind of company situation
um but broadly speaking I think that uh
the the UK is trying to show that it is
open and I think it's really really
important that it does and one of the
successes of the UK has been
cross-border activity and how do you
ensure that that is still the the
sentiment that is carried around the
world all right Stephen that's us I
could talk to you all day but we've got
to leave it there I'm afraid thanks very
much for joining me today
a bit of breaking news uh to bring you
that we've received during the last few
moments and uh members of the unite
Union uh their local government members
are preparing to ballot for strikes this
summer after rejecting the latest payoff
the unite General Secretary Sharon
Graham has said in the last few moments
our members undertake vital Frontline
roles that ensure local communities are
well maintained safe and attractive
places to live they've now drawn A Line
in the Sand and will not accept any
further erosion of their pay we'll have
more on that story throughout the
morning here on Sky News as we get it
other business news now and Lloyd's
banking group has today reported a
pre-tax profit of 2.26 billion pounds
for the first three months of the year
well that was up from one and a half
billion pounds in the same period a year
ago and better than the 1.95 billion
pounds that the market had expected the
Improvement came despite the bank
setting aside some 243 million pounds to
cover loans it does not now expect to be
repaid in full the UK's biggest provider
of current accounts and mortgages said
some 2.2 billion pounds worth of
deposits was redrawn during the period
reflecting the competitive savings
market and the need for some customers
to pay tax bills in January
the consumer Healthcare Group behind
Brands such as Sensodyne toothpaste
Central multivitamins and panoral Pain
Relief has held the end of Chinese lock
dance for better than expected sales
during the first three months of the
year halian reported sales at 2.99
billion pounds for the quarter that was
up 13.7 percent on the same period last
year which has helped also by price
increases and stronger than expected
demand for cold and flu remedies or
pre-tax profits for the quarter came in
at 542 million pounds that was up 16 and
a half percent on the same period a year
ago but was slightly shy of expectations
the share price is currently off by just
over 3 percent
Barrett development said this morning
that it was continuing to see a recovery
in reservations the UK's largest house
Builder by stock market value said that
reservation activity in the period had
reflected the more challenging backdrop
for first-time buyers but resilient
demand among existing homeowners is that
the limited homes for sale in The Wider
markets the Energy Efficiency of new
homes and the backdrop of significant
increases in rents had all helped to
support demand
I'm the Chief Financial Officer of RS
group the components distributor has
resigned after admitting to having had a
personal relationship with a colleague
David eagam has been with the company
for seven years during which time he's
twice served as acting chief executive
and the company has been promoted to the
ftse 100 who Mr Egan said today
following a detailed review by the board
I recognize that there have been some
shortcomings of judgment on my part and
my actions have fallen short of the high
standards expected of RS leadership
therefore it is right for me to step
down from my role
foreign
results and trading updates from house
builders and the builders Merchant
sector have pointed to a downturn
inactivity but there are some operators
bucking the trend Lords group trading a
specialist distributor at building
Plumbing Heating and DIY Goods today
reported a pre-tax profit of 12.8
million pounds for 2022 which was up
69.6 on 2021 the shares are currently
ahead by six and a half percent who are
joining me now is the chief executive of
laws group trading Shankar Patel Shanker
welcome to you I mean you're focused on
the repairs and maintenance and
Improvement Market rather than
construction do you think that's play to
your strengths in this this period
yes it has um our markets are incredibly
resilient
um you know RMI which accounts for 76 of
our group revenue is very supportive of
as the majority of our products are sold
uh are essential items and we haven't
seen a significant downturn in that as
as uh we might have in in the house
building industry and and in particular
anybody who supplies into that sector
which are the products most in demand
um at the moment you know it because we
sell a very wide range of products um we
do see demand ebb and flow across these
categories um previously Paving which
was a category that did very well post
covid is is now you know coming back to
its um its Norms but Timber which um had
increased in price
um quite significantly postcoded um has
now dropped in price and again is
becoming a leading um product category
for us
um cement cells brick cells whilst not
as strong as as last year in volume
terms are still holding up
um in our rnmi segment
that's very interesting I mean if if
I've read you correctly you're almost
saying that you think inflation has
peaked in a lot of your product
categories
um across our categories yes
um you still have underlying inflation
in in products that are energy intensive
um anything that is an energy intensive
will still depending on the
manufacturer's hedging um strategy may
still face some some price increases
there are some um carbon taxes in in
some of these products that that are
flowing through to to price increases
but but products such as Timber and
including Paving have come down in price
so overall we're seeing you know some
still continuing but other product areas
coming down in price so the average
increase is not as Stark as it was
um previously in the last two years and
what about your ability to pass on those
cost increases to customers
thus far in the last few years it has
been um has been possible you know
Supply constraints has has ensured that
um for consumers it's more around
availability than necessarily around
price especially with the consumers have
been committed who have committed to
products
um uh because they're in in build but
the the the the side of our business
that is quite resilient to product price
inflation being passed through is is the
plumbing and heating and that is a a
pure RMI product we can't see a
situation where if you've lost Heating
in your home or hot water that you
wouldn't want to replace the product
that actually supplies that regardless
of whether the price has increased or
not and product price inflation in that
area has not been as significant as some
of the building materials which are a
lot more energy intensive
um so so we see ourselves well
positioned to be able to pass through
product price increases but hopefully
we're now seeing a plateau in the rate
of increase and something more more
palatable for our consumers and
customers now what that's very
interesting now one of the interesting
things about your business you are very
very acquisitive I think you've done
something like 15 Acquisitions over the
last five years what do you look for
when you buy a business
so we have three key uh requirements um
one is a locational
um fit so if there's a business that's
either within our geography that
provides us with a bolt-on Edition in
that geography that's obviously
um a business that we would look at we
look at businesses that are well run
with um but decent you know Branch level
management teams but perhaps with owners
who want to to to now relieve themselves
or what we call the burden of ownership
so where there is potentially a
retirement or a succession issue those
sort of businesses
um are well placed for us to take them
over because we have a very
people-centric Focus you know our our
acquisition strategies around making
sure that the businesses that we buy
retain the teams and actually we grow
and develop the teams of the businesses
that we purchase and then another
element is is product extension so we're
we have product specialism that
currently we do we don't have in our
group we look out to see if there's
Acquisitions that we can make within our
disciplined um price range that add that
specialism to our to our business and
last year we bought a business in the
dry lining and insulation distribution
Market Something That We're Not
prevalent in that's brought a degree of
specialism to our business we bought a
business in boiler spares again
something that we didn't have in our in
in our in our collection of Brands and a
business that serves the roofing market
so again we look out for geography
um uh people and and then product
expansion
all right Shankar we have to leave it
there I'm afraid good to talk to you
this morning thank you thank you very
much
my first time buyers are looking for
smaller properties as mortgage rates
continue to rise well that's according
to the property website zoopla its
latest house price index suggests that
while three bedroom homes remain top of
the list for people taking their first
step on the property ladder that has
been a shift in demand towards two bed
Flats the average asking price of a
three bedroom first time buyer home is
now 230 000 pounds well the average
price tag for a two bedroom property is
around 210 000 pounds well joining me
now is Richard Donald he's executive
director at zuplo Richard welcome to you
I mean the big thing that jumped out of
the results from or the index for me is
that uh by demand is down 42 year on
year why is is that down to interest
rate Rises yes it's all down to the
strength of the market over the pandemic
you know that once in a lifetime you
know reevaluation of the housing you
need so yes year-on-year metrics and
housing don't look great but if you
compare back to say a normal year of
like 2019 actually buy a demand is
holding up much better than you'd
expected at the end of last year yeah I
mean it was interesting that statement
from Barrett developments that I've
touched on earlier in the program
really resilient uh State of Affairs is
it cheaper though now to buy them to
rent
well the first first time buyers are
already key audience group for house
builders we've had help to buy that's
now ended I think in many markets
outside London the south east a renter
looking to buy the home they rent their
mortgage repayments would be up to 30
less than their rent even at four and
five percent mortgage rates as long as
they can come up with that deposit and
that's the biggest constraints on
first-time buyers and I think you know
we're seeing sales volumes improve
demand is down but you know the Run rate
of sales being agreed is 15 above the
five-year average so there's there's a
motivation to move out there even though
we've got much higher mortgage rates
yeah and yet affordability for
first-time buyers who are the lifeblood
of the market is is clearly becoming an
issue it is I mean it's to be a
first-time buyer now you need to be on
about 55 000 household income this is
why we're seeing the shift into smaller
properties but first-time bars are also
taking longer mortgage terms which gets
you up to 20 more buying power today but
you end up paying your bank 50 more in
mortgage interest payments over the life
of your mortgage and I think working
from home also gives people more
flexibility rather than waiting for
longer as a Buy near work you can now
for those that can work flexibly look
further afield yeah interesting now one
of the other things that jumped out in
the report today is the fact that one in
four properties has seen the asking
price reduced when when did you last see
those sort of conditions well that's
getting better actually because we've
just seen quite a big repricing of
asking prices the market was so hot over
the whole of the pandemic people were
getting 100 of the asking price or even
higher the market was just so strong and
actually the real price recorrection has
happened with people sellers just having
to get realistic again now and take a
discount of up to four to five percent
so whilst homeowners made 45 000 over
the pandemic on average they're having
to give away fifteen thousand as a
discount so they're still up uh but yes
there's a there's a repricing we think
the worst of the price Falls are over
now and I think you know I think we're
gonna have a pretty soft recorrection
in-house prices so no uh big correct I
mean when you call a talk about a soft
correction what do you mean we think the
share prices are going to be flat to
down by one percent
um but I say it's it's that it's that
widening of the discount to asking price
it's taking a lot of the strain in the
face of all these interest rate Rises
well I think that I think
mortgage rates have come down to sort of
averaging about four to four and a half
percent now and the fact for many
first-time buyers outside land on the
Southeast it's cheaper to buy than to
rent it shows the resilience in the
market and I think a lot of the um a lot
of the policy changes introduced by the
bank of England
um the limits on loan to income that
affordability stress testing have
provided a much more resilience to
higher rates than you would have
expected and it's probably good news
we've had that regulation and has saved
us from us of an overpricing and then a
recorrection I think you're slightly at
odd with the Delights of the Halifax so
they're a bit more bearish than you are
yeah I think a lot of the banks have put
out I think Santa there last week said
10 price full so I think that's economic
modeling and capital modeling purposes
you know we're just trying to look at
what's really going to happen in the
market and we can see from our own data
that the Market's just more resilient
than economic models might have
suggested I think a lot of people be
very pleased to hear you say it Richard
good to see you this morning thank you
still to come here on Ian King live
we're gonna have a look at how the
markets are doing this Wednesday morning
stay with us
[Music]
that's great thank you
so we went to the Yorkshire Three Peaks
and there were 68 of us who attempted to
do the Three Peaks some of us managed
the two peaks
um and actually quite a big group
managed the Three Peaks we had the most
horrendous weather it was uh it really
was the hardest challenge we've ever
done as the charity
um and I mean from five miles in we were
walking in puddles inside our shoes wow
it was it just wet completely through
and I think
um to see all these people do this walk
and and
I had
um one of the guys who did it text me
afterwards and said look I've got to the
top of one of the mountains I thought I
can't do any more of this but then I
thought about Ian and the boys and I
thought what they'd been through and
with them in in his mind it just kept
him going you're raising money so they
can donate money can't they yeah they
can donate money through our page which
I can't remember the Oscar's pptc.org
yeah so that again that's quite
complicated Oscar's
pbtc.org okay fine we'll make sure that
we put that on our Twitter a little bit
later on
um
I was going to ask you about other
events what other events have you done
uh we've done Snowden a couple times
scar fell and then last year we did Ben
Nevis did you which did you find was the
trickiest of all of them Ben Nevis did
you but this one's definitely taken the
top of the hardest because of the
weather do you think yeah probably yeah
it sounds as though it was really really
difficult how much money do you think
you've raised for this charity I'm
pretty sure we've raised about 20
000 once oh that's amazing I think if we
make it past 22 000 pound it will be the
event that's raised the most money for
us ever
foreign
news to bring you on the sporting front
in the last few minutes we've learned
that Leeds United has sacked its manager
Javi Gracia and he's been replaced at
the newspapers were widely predicting
Yesterday by Sam allardyce Leeds of
course have only four matches left this
season and I think the first of them is
against Manchester City so uh big Sam no
pressure there
onto the markets now and last night
sell-off on Wall Street to us followed
by declines over most of the Asia
Pacific region overnight Shanghai was
the only major Market in the region to
post games uh you can ignore Tokyo which
is in the top left-hand corner of the
screen there that is closed for a public
holiday Sydney was off another one
percent following yesterday's unexpected
interest rate rise from The Reserve Bank
of Australia well in Europe equities
have been largely in positive territory
this morning following some reasonably
good company results as you can see only
the Ibex in Madrid is in negative
territory right now talking points on
Continental Europe this morning include
unicredit Italy's biggest bank is up
nearly six percent in Milan that's five
percent now and that's after its
quarterly earnings beat expectations
we're here in London the ftse 100 has
all been in positive territory for most
of the morning it's uh 14 points to the
good right now by some of the consumer
and Mining stocks the leading Blue Chip
Gainer right now is Pearson which is
currently ahead by nine percent it fell
by 15 yesterday following a profits
warning from its U.S peer check on the
Dan's side well I mentioned RS group
earlier on the departure of the Chief
Financial Officer that's uh clip two
percent from the share price there
outside the ftse 100 TI fluid systems is
ahead by some 15 following the trading
update but Aston Martin Lagonda the
shares there are off some two percent
that's despite the company reducing its
quarterly losses on the Forex Exchange
Market well the S dollar has been on the
back foot following news at U.S job
openings fell for a through a straight
month in March as you can see Sterling
is ahead by nearly a third of one
percent against the Greenback it was up
by more than that earlier on the pound
unchanged against the Euro The single
currency meanwhile similarly up by just
over a third of one percent against the
US dollar as for the oil price well that
this morning hit its lowest level since
the 24th of March amid growing concerns
over demand following expected interest
rate Rises this week a battle of Brent
crude will currently set you back
73.94 about that is off a little under
two percent on the session or joining me
today is the head of investment at
interactive investor Victoria scholar
Victoria good to see you this morning
let's start with Lloyd's um fairly uh
good good set of numbers I thought the
share price has barely moved
yeah you're right we saw that quarterly
pre-tax profit figure beat expectations
you know on the one hand it's been
benefiting from the rising rate
environment which has clearly helped to
boost its bottom line through higher
Returns on lending products but on the
other hand there's the macroeconomic
backdrop to contend with there's a
growing risk of loans turning sour
um you know businesses and individuals
could find themselves in financial
trouble so to prepare for this Lloyd's
has been upping its Provisions for
potential bad loans possibly why the
stock is not particularly uh moving
higher or sharply lower
um you know Lloyd's also suffered from
heavy deposit outflows because customers
are looking elsewhere browsing around
for more attractive savings rates in a
rather competitive market at the moment
and then of course there's the backdrop
of the turmoil in the banking sector
which is weighed heavily on the U.S
mid-sized Banks yesterday but has been
weighing on the sector more broadly
globally in the last couple of months
now also updating the market today is
Haley and I mean the thing that struck
me here Victoria is uh the ease with
which this company has been able to pass
on price increases I mean it's another
illustration I guess of why inflation
remains elevated despite all these rate
hikes
yeah you're right we've heard this so
many times about companies passing on
these additional cost pressures for
consumers in terms of higher prices but
unfortunately that didn't translate late
into stronger earnings it's first
quarter adjusted earnings per share
missed analysts expectations and a lot
of its sales growth has been driven by
price increases rather than volume
growth in its key markets and its
profits margins actually got squeezed uh
despite this shift higher in terms of
Crisis so that's kind of ringing alarm
bells and possibly why the stock is
under pressure today
what did you make of Barrett
developments again I mean I thought that
was an easy issue you know Steady As She
Goes trading update again the shares
have barely moved today
yeah I mean it says it's on track to
deliver full-year profits
um and it achieved pretty good strong
forward sales
um but they are down year on year
clearly uh the housing market is under
pressure still reeling from the mini
budget after mortgage rates were soaring
um but you know we have that Nationwide
house price index out this week that
pointed to a tentative recovery and the
stock and other stocks in the sector are
up quite sharply this year I think
Barrett's up about 20 widely
outperforming uh the ftse 100 with
investors trying to kind of look ahead
to the potential for a rebound in the
housing market uh as the bank of England
approaches the peak of the rate hiking
cycle and as inflation hopefully starts
to come down in the months ahead
now what did you make of further rally
and Pearson this morning Victor I mean
it's absolutely
extraordinary fall yesterday really on
the back of one of its peers in the U.S
saying it was uh worried about weakening
Demand on the back of Chachi PT
yeah well this was a stock that was very
much one of the winners of 2022 I think
it was one of the best performers on the
ftse 100 last year but it seems to have
fallen out of favor this year uh you
know wanted to position itself as the
Netflix for Education publishing a
subscription service for all those uh
sort of Education needs online
um but it does look as though the sector
is now facing pressures from AI like you
say chat gtpt Weighing on its rival with
the potential read across from Pearson
as well
now what about the U.S federal reserve
Victoria I mean we heard from Stephen
Cohen in BlackRock earlier saying uh he
thought it was nailed on another rate
hike tonight is is that your estimation
yeah I think that another 25 basis point
hike today is likely of course we've got
the uncertainty in the backdrop of the
banking sector to contend with the FED
certainly will be paying close attention
to that but we have seen that the feds
stream of rate hikes over the last year
and a half have been starting to weigh
on the economy we had that disappointing
uh U.S labor market data yesterday the
jolts figure hitting a near two-year low
and of course the CPI data has been
coming down it's at five percent now for
March it's ninth consecutive uh decline
so clearly these rate hikes are starting
to take hold within the U.S economy and
indeed uh the US dollar so perhaps this
could be the final rate hike for a while
okay Victoria gotta leave it there I'm
afraid good to see you this morning
thank you
a bit of breaking news uh to bring you
now not uh Terribly Happy news I'm
afraid uh Serbian police have confirmed
that eight children and their guard have
been killed in a shooting at a school in
Belgrade the capital that is the current
scene on the ground there
more on that as we get it here on Sky
News
still to come here only in King life
Pandora the world's biggest affordable
jewelry make retailer has predicted a
good year for sales I'll be hearing next
from its chief executive
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back our Pandora the world's
biggest affordable jewelry retailer said
this morning that sales this year will
be better than expected the Danish
company best known for its customizable
silver charms and bracelets reported
sales for the first three months of the
year of 5.85 billion Danish krona that's
692 million pounds it was up three
percent on the same months last year
well while the United States is the
company's largest and most important
Market I asked the chief executive
Alexander latzich what he'd been seeing
in China
China as you know has been kind of in a
lockdown mode for for quite some time it
reopened in in January and actually q1
has been uh you know sequentially better
and better actually in April we we
posted a positive like for like growth
for the first time in in many many
months so so that's kind of a A plus uh
however I can see that the the kind of
comeback of of the Middle Market
customer in China is much slower than
what we experienced when we came out of
the pandemic in in particular here in
Europe where we quite quickly came back
to pre-pandemic type of behaviors it's
it's happening in China but at a much
lower rate than than what we've seen and
what have you been doing with pricing so
far this year have you been able to
recoup all of your costs
so we did some pricing action in quarter
four of last year's on average we raised
our prices by three to four points
uh we we also assumed that there would
be a an elasticity which would say what
you gain on the top you're losing volume
so the elasticity would be one but
structurally then of course your your
profit and loss statement uh ends up in
a slightly better place than before and
that benefit is then there to offset
some of the rise in in inflationary uh
components uh we haven't done any any
more than that we're going to see
through uh through this year but but
we're quite pleased with the the
reaction it was as we had expected so so
that's a that's a pretty good outcome
for the brand you've been putting a lot
more emphasis recently on design what
kind of things have you been doing
so and we have a couple of platforms as
we keep talking about there's some
moments which is the charms and bracelet
platform we've introduced a new bracelet
for the first time in 20 years we've
designed a new studded chain bracelet
and that has had a very positive
reaction from the market uh then of
course we keep bringing new charms and
charm Innovation so there's nothing
spectacularly different there
necessarily then on our Timeless
arranges more Timeless type of jewelry
we've for the first time introduced a
little bit of a heart-shaped and put
some color into that range which had a
very nice
reception during the Valentine's Day and
then on Pandora me which is the link the
bracelet we're bringing uh more charms
into that range and some additional
products so that's kind of on the
existing line come Q3 we're going to
expand our diamonds range quite
substantially so those are probably in
in terms of in the design Island product
area the interesting news coming to
Consumers this year now last year you
launched your first collection of lab
grown diamonds in the United States are
you still seeing plenty of demand there
yeah I mean this is a long game one has
to be aware of because there's we're
entering the smaller portion of the
diamond Market roughly 10 percent of of
all diamonds sold today are in lab
created this is however growing at an
interesting clip uh and it's new for us
so so our entry into this is is really
strategic and it's going to take a bit
of time but we can definitely see that
there's continuously uh greater and
greater interest in this proposition
being offered by Pandora diamonds only
account for around 36 percent of global
jewelry sales right now do you think
that has scope to increase with the
Advent of lab grown diamonds
I mean if you think about it the today
if you want to buy a diamond that's Out
Of Reach for many many uh consumers when
we when Pandora and other people in
let's say in the middle of the market
introduce this it comes at a different
value proposition so so if you kind of
think about that then very likely you
can see an expansion of of the number of
carrots being sold to customers going
into the future that that is not an
unlikely development
[Music]
time to have a look at this morning's
business pages and the financial time
splashes its print edition with
yesterday's sell-off in education stocks
including Pearson following a profits
warning from chaga leading player in the
market in which it said the interest
from students in the AI chatbot chat GPT
was hurting its sales the ft is
currently leading its Digital Editions
meanwhile with a report that a Russian
spy network has acquired sensitive
technology from EU companies to fuel
Vladimir Putin's war in Ukraine even
after a us-led Crackdown on the covert
smuggling ring the times leads its
business pages with the fca's proposed
listings changes to listings rules it
also reports on its business front page
that Dyson is to spend 100 million
pounds on a new Technology Center in
Bristol as part of a five-year program
of Investments totaling two and
three-quarter billion pounds well that
story also makes the business front page
of the Daily Telegraph which also
reports that Dyson is planning to build
a Next Generation battery plant in
Singapore to power its vacuum cleaners
and hair dryers but the paper leads with
the fca's proposed changes to listings
rules no time for a paper reviewer today
I'm afraid but a reminder to check out
the inking live podcast which you can
find by scanning the QR code on your
screen now it's available now wherever
you get your podcast including the Sky
News app Apple and Google podcasts and
Spotify
well still to come here only in King
live the travel platform trivago's
posted a rise in sales this morning I'll
be speaking to its chief executive after
this short break stay with us
[Music]
so we went to the Yorkshire Three Peaks
and there were 68 of us who uh attempted
to do the Three Peaks some of us managed
the two peaks
um and actually quite a big group
managed the Three Peaks we had the most
horrendous weather it was uh it really
was the hardest challenge we've ever
done as the charity
um and I mean from five miles in we were
walking in puddles inside our shoes wow
it was it just went completely through
and I think
um to see all these people do this walk
and and
I had
um one of the guys who did it text me
afterwards and said look I've got to the
top of one of the mountains I thought I
can't do any more of this but then I
thought about Ian and the boys and I
thought what they'd been through and
with them in in his mind it just kept
him going you're raising money so they
can donate money can't they yeah they
can donate money through our page which
I can't remember the Oscar's pptc.org
yeah so that again that's quite
complicated Oscar's
pbtc.org okay fine we'll make sure that
we put that on our Twitter a little bit
later on
um
I was going to ask you about other
events what other events have you done
uh we've done Snowden a couple times
scar fell and then last year we did Ben
Nevis did you which did you find was the
trickiest of all of them Ben Nevis did
you but this one's definitely taken the
top of the hardest because of the
weather do you think yeah probably yeah
it sounds as though it was really really
difficult how much money do you think
you've raised for this charity I'm
pretty sure we've raised about 20
000 ones wow that's amazing I think if
we make it past 22 000 pound it will be
the event that's raised the most money
for us ever
thank you
[Music]
welcome back now the travel Industry
Recovery from covid restrictions
continues Trivago the global Hotel
search platform says demand's been
robust during the first quarter of 2023
the german-based company which offers
accommodation in more than 190 countries
posted a 9 rise in revenues to 111
million euros and that's up on the same
period last year about nine percent as I
say joining me now is trivago's chief
executive Axel heater Axel welcome to
you
um what's been happening to average
booking values
I mean if you compared to last year
prices are up you know so we see the
impact of inflation obviously of course
and travel as well and also on the price
of accommodation
and it's an American Tourist in
particular back in Europe with a
Vengeance what are the hotel categories
they go for the most
yeah I mean I guess the if you're paid
for an InterContinental flight you're
more likely to go for an expensive hotel
and you're 100 right you can see the
impact of the exchange rate movements in
the in the travel pattern so Americans
are more likely to go to Europe to to
Leverage The the better exchange rate
and Europeans are less likely to go to
the US compared to last year
obviously China has reopened this year
as well has that been a big driver of
sales for you
yeah Asia is is actually very
interesting I mean we are not um active
in China but China is obviously a very
important destination for a lot of our
Asian platforms
um Taiwan Singapore Hong Kong South
Korea Japan the other Big Driver of our
Asian business has been the reopening of
Japan in in the last couple of months
and um we expect a very very strong
recovery across Asia for this year
it's been very striking Japan is working
quite hard to Market itself as a tourist
destination in a way that I can never
remember is that does I have much
resonance with consumers yet is it
gaining traction
yeah absolutely I mean we are very happy
with the performance of our Japanese
platform
um and it's both outbound and inbound
traffic
um into Japan
um that has picked up a lot over the
last couple of months
have you been at all taken aback by the
strength of demand given the the sheer
number of interest rate Rises we've had
in the Eurozone in the United States in
the UK just about everywhere it doesn't
really seem to have affected demand
yeah I mean it it has to a certain
extent I mean the we just run some user
research and um in the UK and more than
50 of um of Brits are willing to tap
into their savings so like in the last
two years where people have used their
savings for their their vacation
um that's that's one side the other
thing is that we see a change in
Behavior so we see that Travelers are um
going for slightly shorter trips and we
see that they are going for cheaper
destinations so as an example Spain is
losing at the expense of um of turkey
for a warm summer beach vacation London
is using it losing at the expense of
Istanbul also Travelers are going for
slightly cheaper destinations that offer
a very similar experience
you mentioned London there there's a big
uh debate going on in this country right
now about the fact that the government
has taken away that free shopping vat uh
free shopping from from visitors the
luxury goods sector and the hotel sector
here are very upset about it do you
think it's having a visible impact on on
tourist numbers in the UK
I mean on the absolute tourist numbers I
I don't think it will have a big impact
to be honest it will have an impact on a
certain um traveler segment yeah so so
those that are going for luxury shopping
so the the top end of the market
um so educating some think that there is
some risk for certain kind of retail
outlets certain hotels but for the
overall Market London is is our top
destination globally so um everybody's
going to London not only the ultra rich
and to briefly Axel if you were pleased
what about the competitor landscape I
mean over the weekend Hyatt Hotels has
just bought Mr and Mrs Smith are you
seeing more competitor activity
so I we we do expect uh M1A in the
market
um actually people have expected more
M1A for now quite a while
um in on the on the hotel chain side
their consolation has happened before
the pandemic and and I think that will
continue
um and it will help
um or tell companies to take out some
costs and to leverage economies of scale
okay Axel we have to leave it there
appreciate you joining me today thank
you
that's it from me there's much more on
the Sky News Mobile app and on the
website with reporting video content and
Analysis from our business team I'm back
at 10 o'clock tomorrow morning hope very
much to see you then in the meantime do
stay tuned coming up after this short
break it's Jane second with of course
all the build up that we get at this
time of the week for prime minister's
questions thanks for joining me today
foreign
[Music]